I really believe we pass socialism you  know we've just stepped over socialism  we're into communism that's what's  happening if you look at the justice  department the FBI you look at the kind  of things that are going on with law  enforcement and what they're doing we  have forgotten them so he's gone from  supporting law enforcement to now that  the FBI served a search warrant at  Mar-A-Lago law enforcement is evidence  of Communism about socialism we're into  communism  we're into Soviet Union stuff  it's very bad and it's very dangerous  for this country and people are angry  about it yeah Trump continuing to have  no idea what socialism is what communism  is the difference between the two or  whether there's any of it here in the  United States as orange and sweaty as  ever